[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a guilty verdict is handed down in the
sarah lawrence college cult federal
trial perhaps in larry ray's mind these
videotapes were records of confessions
that would somehow exonerate him but
that's not how the jury viewed it plus
we've learned of the very tragic death
of amara mar luke a student here at
portland state university a one-time
portland state university football
player is charged in the death of
another student and the state calls a
rebuttal witness as a defense wraps up
its case in the olympian attempted
murder trial when i first met with him
he was very very tearful i mean he was
crying uncontrollably he almost at times
was hard to console him but first no
charges are filed in the shooting death
of 22 year old black man amir lock it
would be unethical for us to file
charges in a case
in which we know that we will not be
able to prevail law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmart minnesota
officials announced no charges will be
filed for the officers involved in the
shooting death of 22 year old amir locke
locke was killed in february of this
year when officers performed a no knock
warrant at the apartment where he was
staying body camera footage shows
officers entering the room where locke
was sleeping on the couch next to him
was a handgun that he legally owned
within seconds officer mark handman shot
locke he died as a result of his
injuries at the time officials were
searching for lock's cousin 17-year-old
makai speed who was wanted in connection
to a murder investigation speed has
since been arrested and charged with
second-degree murder on wednesday
hennepin county attorney michael freeman
and minnesota attorney general keith
ellison announced no charges would be
filed in amir lock's death they did
acknowledge locke's name was not on the
no knock warrant and that he was a
victim in the shooting but say
minnesota's use of force statute would
not support charges in the shooting
one thing amir was not
amir was not a suspect
our investigation found no evidence that
he had any role in the homicide
investigation that brought the police to
his door at 6 48 on february 2nd
amir was a victim
he never had he never should have been
called a suspect we have determined that
under the precedent
then the laws that we have
we cannot file criminal charges
current law only allows us to evaluate
the case from the perspective of a
reasonable police officer
and that language is from the fourth
amendment of the u.s constitution
and relevant cases and statutes
we're not allowed to evaluate the case
from the perspective of the victim
with all the available evidence
we would not be able to prove in court
that officer henneman's use of force was
not authorized under the law beyond a
reasonable doubt
it would be unethical for us to file
charges in a case in which we know that
we will not be able to prevail because
the law does not support support the
charges
ahead of wednesday's press conference
minnesota officials revealed no charges
will be filed through a press release
after that lawn cry network contributor
and podcast host lieutenant sean
stix-larkin appeared on dan abrams live
to discuss why he believed parts of the
release were misleading
they talked about having paramedics
basically present or on standby and it
just talks about the foreseeable
violence from this type of search
warrant i have been on
honestly i'm going to guess somewhere
between 500 and a thousand 800 to a
thousand search warrants over 25 years
we had paramedics present on every
single search warrant we went on whether
it was for narcotics or for a homicide
suspect whether we're looking for
burglary loot we have paramedics present
because there's always a likelihood
that a shooting or an injury could occur
on a search warrant and just the wording
in their uh you know release again made
it sound like they anticipated or were
looking for something like this to
happen is why they had paramedics
present we always have them present
police officers are almost always the
bad guys i believe you said it there
were other people present in this
apartment when the police served a
search warrant they didn't point a gun
at police officers the police officers
were not forced to use deadly force
against them
it's just uh you know we just kind of
keep on catching this no matter what
happens
joining us today is the civil rights
attorney for amir logs family jeffrey
storm jeff why do you think charges
should have been filed and which ones if
any
you know brian based upon the facts that
we saw here in the video evidence you
know we have a situation where from the
outset the officers come in they don't
announce before they breach the
threshold they encounter a mirror he's
obviously asleep and the officers based
upon policy and training are supposed to
be cognizant to barriers of
understanding and so clearly if
someone's asleep and jarred awake they
need an opportunity to understand what's
going on here there was a series of
muddled screaming going on around him
and it actually took kicking the couch
to wake him up
given that he was given no opportunity
to save himself
and he was someone who was a lawful gun
owner and had his gun within arm's
distance while he was sleeping which is
very common so here the jury at a
minimum should have been given similar
charges to what we saw
uh kim potter ultimately get convicted
of at the very least second-degree
manslaughter for culpable negligence and
then first-degree manslaughter for a
reckless use of a firearm resulting in
death now jeff i know it's a different
state altogether but do you think the
recent acquittal of brett hankinson had
anything to do with a.g ellis's decision
not to go forward
you know lawyers always look at
precedent uh you know i honestly don't
have any great insight as to whether or
not it did what i'll say is there are
obviously a number of competing
political factors here in minnesota uh
that uh create more than enough issues
that could influence a decision maker
all right so no charges for the officers
we just heard that but can the city be
held accountable for locke's death
absolutely and and so can the officers
involved uh so you know obviously we're
involved because we're civil attorneys
and one of the ways the city can be held
accountable is through a claim for
unconstitutional policies and practices
which we don't have enough time to go
through the number of unconstitutional
policies and practices that have been
reflected by the minneapolis police
department as it stands now the
department of justice is doing a policy
and practice investigation and i think
the likelihood is very high that
ultimately a federal monitor will be
appointed to run the minneapolis police
department and amir's killing will only
i think make that happen faster
all right thank you jeff i know that
your time is precious but we appreciate
you being here with us and we hope to
see you again soon still ahead on law
and crime daily a portland state
university student murdered as another
student is arrested in connection to the
case but first the defense may soon
wrest its case in the olympian attempted
murder trial when you could expect to
see closing arguments next
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
defense rested its case in the trial for
ex-olympian michael barrison accused of
attempted murder in new jersey the state
in turn calls a rebuttal witness
barriston is facing two counts of
attempted murder after he shot lauren
canorack in the chest twice and shot her
then boyfriend robert goodwin back in
2019. the dispute followed ongoing back
and forth arguments about canarac and
goodwin's living arrangement on
barrison's farm at the time of the
shooting the two were living in an
apartment on the property while he while
barristone trained canarak in dressage
horseback riding barristone's defense
team argued he feared for his life at
the time of the shooting and even
suffered from mental health issues on
wednesday defense called a psychologist
hired to evaluate barristown to the
stand during his testimony he told
jurors barriston had told him he
believed kanorak had declared war on him
the prosecution then called a forensic
psychologist as rebuttal to bears own
psychiatrist testifying he told the jury
about the time he spent with barizone
do you know how much time you spent with
michael barissone in this case uh yes i
spent
13.25 hours what was his demeanor when
you met with him
well when i first met with him he was
very very tearful i mean he was crying
uncontrollably he almost at times was
hard to console him
um he was very upset about the whole
thing and he became animated at times
particularly when discussing uh lauren
and
robert goodwin and the whole
circumstances uh with respect to that he
would stand up get animated and so on he
was very emotional
about it um but he
you know he after i caught he calmed
down and he participated fine he was
cooperative
completely answered my questions
except for some resistance towards the
end
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney nima romani and co-host terry
austin nina the defense
flew sorry through their case but what
points did they raise and did any make
you think
i think there's some reasonable doubt
here
i don't think the defense case did much
to move the needle here i know the
conventional wisdom and the temporary
insanity cases you got to call these
experts defense called theirs the state
called their psychologist i think they
washed each other out the reason you
don't need it in a case like this is
it's a very rare for someone to take two
to the chest and survive this case was
about lauren and rob's testimony i
thought lauren testified okay i thought
rob testified poorly this is a case
based on cross-examination and you never
know what a jury is going to do when it
comes to self-defense right i would tend
to agree maybe not much from the defense
but um closing is now being scheduled
for monday the prosecution did put
forward a rebuttal case terry how do you
think that went
well the rebuttal was all about those
medical experts dr simran was the
defense psychiatrist and he's the one
who said that barristone was delusional
he had chronic depression and then dr
hansen he was the one who was the
psychologist and he basically said for
the defense that barristone did not know
the difference between right and wrong
and that he didn't know the nature and
quality of his actions the rebuttal
witness basically refuted all of that he
said while he respected simran he didn't
agree with the diagnosis and so i think
he
basically refuted what the defense
experts said we'll see what the jury
thinks yeah i think this is all going to
come down to the closing arguments and
of course the law and crime network has
you covered for galileo gavel coverage
make sure to check that out because i
think that's the only way we're going to
figure out how this all ends
switching now to ohio where closing
arguments are delayed again in the trial
of former icu dr william hussell this as
an affidavit seeks to remove the judge
in the case closings were originally
slated to be presented on monday of this
week but have been delayed four times
law and crime network has reached out to
the judge's staff attorney in the case
who only says there are quote issues
being worked out but wouldn't say more
but on thursday afternoon local station
wosu reported that an affidavit of
disqualification was filed to remove
judge hallbrook the ohio supreme court
later denied the request whosoever's
accused of murdering 14 patients while
practicing medicine as an icu doctor at
mount carmel st anne's hospital in
columbus ohio as of now closing
arguments are set to be presented on
monday we hope
coming up on law and crime daily more
than 10 years after he moved on to the
sarah lawrence college campus averted is
handed down for defendant lawrence ray
plus the lives of two portland state
university students are changed forever
when the body of one student is
recovered and another is arrested
[Music]
welcome back a former portland state
university football player is arrested
after the body of another student is
found just off campus on monday
officials say the body of 19-year-old
amara maruluk was discovered her death
was ruled a homicide and the cause of
death was determined to be a gunshot
wound later that day 20 year old suspect
kenan harpol turned himself in to the
police he was arrested and has since
been charged with second-degree murder
and unlawful use of a weapon
investigators believe that the shooting
was part of a domestic violence incident
but haven't released many more details
in a video statement the president of
portland state university called
marlou's death a terrible loss
we are so saddened
about this horrific event
in a moment like this a president
doesn't have the full words or capacity
to express the heartbreak the sadness
and the mourning that's taking place for
the loss of this amazing student
we try our best with the words that we
have but it's in our hearts in our minds
where we feel the loss
amara was an amazing student who cared
about family and community
she would be so greatly missed and we're
so sorry we wish our heartfelt deepest
condolences and sympathies to the family
and all those people whose life she
touched who will feel this terrible loss
criminal defense attorney nima romani
and co-host terry austin are back as we
break down this tragic shooting and loss
of life nima is it an open and shut case
with harpool turning himself in if not
what more do investigators need to put
forward to close his case
brian it's a very strong case every time
law enforcement arrests someone the same
day you know it's wrong i we don't have
all the facts yet but clearly there was
a gun involved there was some domestic
violence situation at least because he
has been charged with that and we know
when a young woman is killed almost half
the time it's gonna be a boyfriend
husband partner something of that effect
so i expect more evidence to come out in
the coming days and weeks and i expect
harpoo to be convicted or to take a plea
because it seems like a very strong case
so far yeah it's interesting because
that's part of my question here so terry
we've got a confession at least we were
told one i'm looking for this smoking
gun and if those two are put together do
you see this going to trial or harpoon
taking a plea
here's what i think brian i think
initially it will go to trial there's no
question because he turned himself in
but he also initially pled not guilty so
he may try to assert a defense maybe
he'll say that it was a crime of passion
but ultimately ryan i do think he'll
probably have to take a plea based on
the evidence because it does seem strong
so far based on what we've seen he
wasn't released on bond he's in jail
maybe being in jail behind bars will
make him get to a point where he will
want to take a plea particularly if that
evidence is so strong against him and we
heard the parents and the family talking
about this terrible tragedy so i do
think that there will be some pressure
to take a plea yeah um maybe a false
confession argument i don't know but if
i'm looking at the facts of the case and
as terry you said he's still
incarcerated i'm thinking this is going
to be a plea and we're not going to see
much of a trial here but of course here
the law and crime network will keep eyes
on this case and update as it develops
when we come back after weeks of
testimony a verdict is returned in the
sarah lawrence college sex cult federal
trial still ahead hear from law and
crime network's adam classfield who was
at the courthouse when jurors returned
[Music]
welcome back a jury is seated in florida
where an ex-physical therapist will soon
be tried for the murders of his wife
three young children and family dog it
happened in early 2020 just miles from
disney world in celebration florida
that's where prosecutors say 45 year old
anthony toad murdered his family
investigators found their bodies days
after they were killed when officials
attempted to arrest tote on unrelated
charges of insurance fraud in a
jailhouse letter to his father claimed
his wife was to blame for the killings
stay with the law and crime network for
capital gabbro coverage of the case live
coverage will begin with opening
statements they're set to be presented
on monday
and a verdict is reached in the sarah
lawrence sex cult case in new york city
the 62 year old defendant lawrence ray
could spend the rest of his life behind
bars after being found guilty on a
15-count indictment of federal charges
law and crimes adam classfelt joins us
with what it was like the last few weeks
inside the courtroom
it was a very quick verdict
deliberations started at 9 30 in the
morning and by a little after one we
received a notification that there's a
verdict and the verdict was what it was
guilty on all 15 counts of sex
trafficking
racketeering
forced labor extortion money laundering
and other crimes the prosecution said
during summations that he acted like a
crime boss in victimizing these sarah
lawrence students whose lives he entered
in 2010
u.s attorney damien williams or the
southern district of new york described
how he exploited them tortured them one
of his victims claudia drury was 19
years old when they met
and she testified that he coerced her
into a life of sex work to pay back
debts of 2.5 million dollars to larry
ray a very grueling testimony she was on
the stand for
five days in the courtroom when it went
down where the rosario siblings even
their mother marissa rosario testified
about not seeing her children for years
we saw the video of course of dan levin
uh having his tongue
pulled with a set of pliers by ray uh
that is just some of the harrowing
testimony of what he subjected this
group of kids too and now the verdict is
in the jury believed their own eyes they
believed what they saw in the videos
they believed the what they heard in the
audio tapes and they followed the money
trail so a very sordid case 15
counts a very complicated case but it
didn't take the jury too long to bring
it to its conclusion
adam we cannot thank you enough for
bringing this case to us and spending so
much time there in federal court
lawrence ray is set to be sentenced in
september but there is one more trial to
go into the case as rey's alleged
co-conspirator isabella pollock also
faces federal charges
nima one person more than anyone else is
probably watching that verdict and is
terrified and i'm talking about isabella
pollock uh what do you think this
verdict means for her
republican attorneys really gotta take a
look in the mirror when a jury returns a
verdict in four hours
you know you're in trouble as a
co-defendant and there's so much
testimony in this case that's just
so horrific for the defense and there's
video and there's notes and we're
looking at a 15-year mandatory minimum
potential life sentence so if i'm
pollock i do everything i can to plead
to something maybe as a minor role or do
something to get out of a mandatory
minimum because if she goes to trial
she's going to suffer the same rate as
rey and likely going to spend almost the
rest of her life in federal prison yeah
now terry we know the general ranges for
sentencing but we also know the severity
of this case so now that rey was found
guilty on all counts what type of
sentence do you think he will receive
well i think it's going to be on the
very high end of all of those sentences
look we know it's between 15 and life
and if you look at the aggravating
factors and the mitigating factors in
this case the aggravating factors far
outweigh any sort of mitigating factors
we know that he was previously charged
and convicted we don't know whether or
not he's served anything in the
community as far as being a good person
but we saw what happened with those
videos we saw all of the different
victims that he really did torture and
we know the families have been impacted
by all of this so i think at the end of
the day when he is sentenced in
september we're going to see the maximum
imposed if at all possible this is not
the type of person that you want to see
back out on the streets at any point in
time he really is a danger to society
and i think that the judge will come
down hard on him i would tend to agree
especially when i'm thinking about these
impact statements that we're likely to
hear well thank you both for joining us
and thank you for joining us here at law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you